Are they going to be
very personal questions?
Yeah.
Deep.
Like hard hitting.
So you're Brazilian.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Can I just start this,
taking this out of the way?
Knowing you was one of the best
things that happened to me.
I truly love you, Lizzie.
You, too.
And I want everybody
here to know that.
I feel the same way.
And I think this connection
sort of formed from day one
and then got deeper.
I will never forget
the day that we were
doing this scene in the car.
- Yes!
- We really didn't know
each other well.
But, you know, and then we
were stuck in this car.
Yeah.
And we were driving.
There was a crew in
another car shooting us.
And then they said, make a left.
[LAUGHS]
Yeah.
And then we made a left.
Neither of us know how
to drive around Chicago.
And then we ended
up in the freeway.
[LAUGHS]
Yes.
And the radio stopped working.
And I didn't have a cell phone.
And it was like, and I was
a Brazilian dude driving--
This old car.
This old car with no
connection with anyone.
Nope.
Basically, we were
like literally--
We were on our way to Indiana.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, we did contemplate
just continuing to drive--
To drive.
To Indiana, just
never going back.
And I think that after that--
That was it.
That was the moment.
That was--
I was like, I called the AD.
And I was like, "I don't
know where we are."
"Can you please tell
us how to come back?"
Come rescue us.
What is the show about?
[LAUGHTER]
For me, the show is about
this women struggling
to regain her power in
a very tricky situation
because the guy who attacked her
is not a regular serial killer.
He's a dude that travels--
Through time.
And it's like, in
order to do that, she
has the help of this journalist,
this guy that I play,
who is a very complicated
man, and who is also
trying to regain his power.
One of the things that I think
that connects Kirby and Dan
is that they are both very
vulnerable human beings
in a very specific
moment of their lives.
And also sort of
hiding something
about themselves, right?
Hiding a truth
about themselves
that they feel like they
can't expose to anybody else.
In Kirby's case, it's the
trauma that she went through.
And it's the fact that
her whole world shifts.
For me in the beginning,
Kirby is a means for me
to get my big story
about it, which
is my comeback into journalism.
But then there is
something about this woman.
When things change for
you, do you recognize it?
Sometimes.
Other times,
they're just random.
This is a question
that I have for you.
You're always so cool in a set.
Do you ever get nervous?
I don't know if I get
nervous that much anymore.
Emotional stuff, I'm fine.
That doesn't make me nervous.
That I can do.
I know how to do that.
But if I've got a scene
with a lot of dialogue,
I get anxious, or tense.
The scene at the back
of the Bee Happy Bar.
Things change for
me just like that.
And nobody knows any different.
Not only was it a
lot of dialogue,
but it was a lot
of tricky dialogue.
Having to figure out how to
explain the shifts to you
and really wanting
the scene to work,
and really wanting it
to work as a director.
So that's where I
get a little anxious.
Lizzie, I was always like
watching you direct
and acting at the same
time, which is something
that you have done
before, especially
coming from doing a
very strong scene,
and things were going on.
And then at some
point, you said, "cut".
Very sweet.
And I'm like, how does
that work for you?
I've always thought
in terms of editing.
I've always been really aware
of what shots were going
to be used for which moments.
There are times
when I definitely
have to remind myself
not to be the director,
and to just be the
actor, either when
it's a really important
performance moment
for my character, or when
it's an important performance
moment for the other character.
What I love about directing
you is learning how far I could
push you and how
far you could go,
and knowing that
you were totally
happy to be pushed
to go all the way,
practically off of the cliff.
This is him.
I don't know how to explain it.
But this is him.
No, there will be none of that.
This is him.
This is him!
We're not doing any of that.
What are the kind of stories
that you want to tell?
How did you come
across Shining Girls?
For me, I wanted to do a show
that wasn't like something
I had seen before.
What I loved about
this is I've never
done anything that
was as magical.
I've never done anything that
had any sort of time travel
element to it and yet
was really grounded.
The mix of genres, I
think that's very exciting
and kind of unique.
It was never you.
It's this house.
I feel like I should
ask you a question.
You're asking me all
kinds of questions.
I'm a journalist.
Tell me about-- cause I
remember--
no, but you do love journalism.
I do.
I think that journalism is a
very, very important thing.
And I really, really
respect journalists
that keep doing their thing
despite of anything else.
Yeah.
You are still here.
And no one could forget you.
This show has something that's
very interesting and connected
to the world nowadays,
which is women empowerment.
Yeah.
It's about the woman that
survived and struggled
to regain her power,
and also to not allow
that to happen to other women.
I think that's what
Dan and Kirby connect
about, is they want to tell
the women who didn't make it,
who didn't survive.
And they want to
tell their stories.
And they don't want them
to just be forgotten.
You think the world
owes you, and that you
can take whatever you want.
But this is mine.
This was a truly great,
amazing experience in my life.
To be with you, to know
you, to become your friend
for me, the greatest thing.
That's how I feel.
I agree.
And I agree the
greatest thing for me
and the experience
of making the show
has been the
relationship between
you and I that
has developed.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CYMBAL CRASHING]